salut tout le monde aujourd'hui il est
temps de vous avouer quelque chose
l'émission Joueur du Grenier n'est qu'un
produit dérivé
ouais c'est depuis le début en fait on
est juste un support commercial pour
vendre cette poupée alors bon vous en
avez jamais vraiment entendu parler
parce que ça a jamais vraiment marché
dans le commerce je sais pas trop
pourquoi d'ailleurs mais n'oublie pas de
regarder des deux côtés avant de
traverser
l'autoroute ne soyez pas choqué c'est
pas nouveau environ 70 % des sérion a
aimé autant moi avant que vous
maintenant hein c'était des trucs
destinés à nous faire cracher de la tune
pour acheter des jouets comprenez-moi
bien je veux dire il y a eu des
figurines senseya mais elles sont
dérivées du dessin animé mais le dessin
animé senseya n'a pas été créé pour
vendre des figurines sauf le dernier
mais il y a une autre race de dessin
animé qui a été créé uniquement pour
vendre des figurines on en a déjà un peu
parlé j Jo musclore Action Man Dino
rider tortue ninja imaginez pour un
commercial mais c'est le rêve les
enfants se réunissent tous les jours
deux même pour voir une pub de 20
minutes et maintenant bah ça existe
toujours un Pokémon pour les jeux vidéos
ou
Beyblade justement on va commencer par
ça alors c'est parti hyper
vitesse [ __ ] la vie c'est quand même
vachement moins bien que dans les
mangas sincèrement j'adore ce
générique vous pense consomme aachète
nos merd Beyblade sorti en 2001
l'exemple parfait du truc créé
uniquement pour te faire cracher ta Tune
à la base Beyblade si vous vous en
souvenez pas
rappelez-vous on retrouve notre héros
que je vais appeler Sacha avec des
couleurs inversé pardon c'est Tyon qui
part pour l'école et tombe sur un cliché
de bouies il fait un duel contre eux
allez la formule magique à toi l'honneur
tu es prêt prêt merchandising
hyper vitesse non j'étais presque
évidemment gagne grâce à la force
centrifuge oui c'est vrai mais c'est
surtout le plus important c'est le temps
que tu passes à t'entraîner à
perfectionner tes stratégies mais
s'entraîner à quoi c'est des toupies à
la con tu les lances et elle tourne et
puis c'est tout bon allez quand j'ai
entendu ça la première fois et
franchement j'y croyais pas donc avant
de juger comme un con je suis quand même
allé vérifier enfin si d'abord j'ai jugé
comme un con et après je suis allé
vérifier mec et effectivement il y a
l'air d'avoir des techniques de lancer
de toupies donc allez on va dire que je
veux bien y croire après évidemment
schéma classique le héros gagne contre
les Bouis et ça c'est à chaque saison je
veux dire regardez le premier épisode de
la saison 1 maintenant le premier
épisode de la saison 2 faites semblant
d'avoir des idées au moins [ __ ] bon je
sais que c au glich de manga mais ah je
déteste ce truc des méchants qui s'enfu
en courant quand ils viennent de perdre
au cartes ou à la toupie j'ai gagné vous
ne pouvez rien contre moi
ah ça vous pouvez après bon c'est vrai
cette série reprend les clichés des
animés de sport et de combat mais là
c'est des toupies c'est débile mais tu
es pas
blessé mais il va très bien tu peux AR
vous
êtes c'est incroyable mais comment
fait-il pour se relever j'ai pourtant
fait tomber sa tpie bref après avoir
gagné on retrouve grka Bogdanov avec un
autre cliché de manga le N lunette qui
perd un duel de top mais finalement le
héros réussi à gagner parce s'est
entraîné toute la nuit en sautant en
l'air comme un con pour gagner de l'élan
quand il lance sa toupie paure débile
une fois que l'on multiplie l'effet du
double lanceur par celui de la technique
de lancer de Tyson on arrive à une
vitesse de rotation qu fois supérieure à
celle d'une toupie normale que Mar alors
en fait la vitesse est multiplié c'est
bon on s'en fout en fait on voulait
juste avoir un camion avec toi parce que
tout le monde l'a fait alors bon voilà
sauf nous al ah oui tu peux y aller non
mais mais je suis chez moi ici en fait
après la victoire de notre personnage
arrive en toute simplicité
évidemment ah [ __ ] ils m'ont enfin vu
ça fait 15 minutes que j'attends en
prenant cette pause bref bla bla bla
sort ta toupie oh là le héros perd une
première fois contre le méchant puis il
s'entraîne puis il va de nouveau se
battre contre lui puis [ __ ] de merde
arrêtez de parler à vos toupies pass
face à l'offensive drzer bah oui
forcément ça c'est un truc que vous avez
piqué à Pokémon mais Pokémon ça marche
ils ont un cerveau et des oreilles c'est
des animaux mais ça là c'est du
plastique allez vas-y tu peux le battre
allez tu as toujours été là pour
moi quelqu'un veut jouer à ma place bref
finalement le héros réussit à gagner
grâce au dragon dans sa toupie avant de
se faire chasser par la bande de
méchants hors de leur
repère lESAIN ou
sinon lESAIN ok sérieusement cette scène
m'a fait poser la question c'est des
jouets ou c'est des armes
oh mon dieu il a une
toupie bref finalement les héros rentrre
chez eux où ils finissent par parler de
oh mon dieu il y a un dragon dans sa
Tapie est-ce qu'on peut parler de ça là
oou est-ce que tout le monde s'en fout
je vais vous expliquer puisque vous êtes
bouché ton dragon bleu et mon Phénix
rouge ont élu domicile d'un toupie
respective ah ok attends c'est pas des
explications ça et le pire c'est que
quand ils font un match pour la première
fois devant du public personne ne
s'étonne de ça c'est juste ti il y a un
dragon ça per l'hipopè un dragon géant
vient de surgir de la toupie tandis que
oh un phénix vient de jaillir de la
seconde quel drôle de journée mon cher
Jean-Louis enfin bref je vais pas vous
mentir moi je trouve cette série un peu
voilà c'est c'est pas pour le principe
de jouer à la toupie je veux dire moi je
suis sûr que j'aurais eu une série comme
ça quand j'étais mom j'aurais adoré
cette série finalement ça n'est qu'une
fusion entre Pokémon et Oliv tomom et on
retrouve les habituels délires de tous
les animés sportifs j'avais déjà du mal
à croire dans Oliv ett Tom que le public
se déplacé pari milli pour voir des
poussins jouer mais là c'est même plus
des joueurs c'est des toupies minuscules
de 3 cm le mec làhaut il fait
quoi d'ailleurs cette série a subi le
même destin que Yu-Gi-Oh avec ses spinof
de l'enfer vous savez jouer au car sur
des moto tout ça regardez cette série
c'est un spinoff de Beyblade ça
s'appelle Bay whels à la place des
toupies maintenant on tire des roues ah
les neurones ont dû chauffer à l'étage
marketing
y blade Metal Fusion metal fur Metal
Master gvolution V force Shog steels
warriorider outre le fait que c'est quoi
pouro que dans lesu les champions sont
toujours hab comme ça bonjour je suis
champion régional de Beyblade région
poitouante je m'appelle loï comment tu
peux faire 500 épisodes sur des toupies
ça va tourner en rond
après concernant l'aspect jouet c'est
super intelligent on te montre dans la
série le jouet que tu peux acheter
contrairement à Pokémon par exemple qui
se passe dans le jeu finalement Pokémon
c'est assez à l'ancienne comme dessin
animé un Pokémon ça se passe dans le
monde de Pokémon et en ça c'est assez
proche de nos anciens dessins animés
mercantil à nous dans les années 80 en
Occident les premiers dessins animés
basés sur des jouets ça a commencé en 83
avec muscleor et en 84 avec Transformers
et on va aller voir ce que ça donne
alors c'est parti hyper vitesse bon
j'arrête ça bon l'histoire de transform
vous la connaissez donc c'est
des desceptican vous êtes même pas foutu
de pas vous tromper dans leur nom alors
que l'épisode est lancé depuis 12
secondes donc l'histoire commence par
deux autobodes qui ramassent des barres
d'énergie quand c'est déjà ça
çaire à ce moment
etour voilà donc de gentils autobotes
qui s'enfuiti sur une autoroute sur
Cybertron continuez à je suis s qu'il
vontarrêter voyant que la guerre est
bientôt perdue les autob prennent un
vaisseau il décolent mais juste après le
décollage se font aborder par les des
septicon et après ils arrivent voilà
c'est ça va c'est tranquille il y a pas
eu de voyage en Vitesse Lumière il y a
pas eu d'élipse genre on voy un petit
peu non non c'est genre ils ont pris le
vaisseau ils ont piloté 3 minutes et
voilà non parce que d'après la vitesse à
laquelle ils sont arrivés sur Terre
normalement tu lèves les yeux tu la vois
d'ici cbertron le vaisseau des autobotes
se crachent sur terre et 4 millions
d'années plus
tard bon ben je suppose que ça va être
un truc genre il y a un enfant qui un
jour découvre le vaisseau qui clique sur
un bouton et puis ça réactive tout et
mais non pas besoin de justifier c'est
juste
voilà ça redémarre alors du coup
pourquoi 4 millions ok j'ai compris
heureusement qu'ils ont pas eu de mise à
jour sinon ils seraiit jamais revenu à
la vie donc une sone part du vaisseau
scan des avions et ça provoque la
réparation des décepticanes ok alors
pourquoi 4 millions d'années pourquoi
est-ce que personne n'a vu ce vaisseau
extraterrestre gigantesque de la moitié
sort de la montagne alors qu'on est
genre à 800 m de la ville pourquoi le
robot des gentils répare que les
méchants et pourquoi est-ce que les
méchants ne tuent pas les gentils tant
qu'ils sont par terre inoffensif bien je
pourrais vous répondre je pourrais vous
présenter ce superbe robot achète ma
merde achète ma merde
maant donc les décepticon qui sont
sortis du vaisseau s'en vont pour aller
prendre les ressources de la
planète qu'est-ce que tu fais je tire ma
révérence
pourquoi qu'estce que tu fais un je de
regarde qui VO regardez les enfants
c'est la FA des intri qui pu la merde à
la vie merci fait des intrigues qui
puent la merde grâce à toi le scénario
peut continuer c'est tellement con je
vois même pas quoi dire dessus quoi les
méchants se barrent en enjambant les
gentills sans les achever le seul moyen
de rendre ça encore plus con ça aurait
été que Mégatron se barre en faisant un
bisou sur le front d'Optimus de partir
bref outre le fait de violer toutes les
lois de la physique non parce que ça ça
n'est pas possible je sais que c'est des
robots géants que c'est pas possible
quoi qu'il arrive mais ça ça n'est
vraiment pas possible au niveau
moléculaire je veux dire que tu changes
de forme je veux bien mais tu changes
pas de masse alors en fait si on
considère que la masse toi la ferme ça
va moi aussi j'ai regardé ces pas
sorcier bon à part ça je je comprends
pas cette série je comprends pas ces
robots 2 minutes après on les voit voler
là du coup pourquoi est-ce que lui il
s'est fait chier à fuir transformer en
jeep pourri là que ça sert pour passer
inaperçu au milieu des humains ok mais
là c'était dans le désert et toi
pourquoi est-ce que tu te bats avec un
bâton et toi pourquoi est-ce que tu te
transformes en petit fling alors que tu
as un immense canon sur le bras et toi
pourquoi est-ce que tu tu te sers du mec
transformé en petit fling alors que
toimême tu as de canons sur les bras et
en plus tu t'en seras demain pourquoi
est-ce que vous
êtes c'est juste l'épisode ép bien plus
après comme cet épisode o une femme Tom
amouruse des
aut j'en connais qui va avoir droit à
une
bonneceon pe avoir un truc plus stup que
ça que je demandejours ment on finit sur
une petite morale enfin pour être
honnête Transformers avaient failli
avoir des messages d'intérêt général
mais ils ont jamais été diffusés et on
peut comprendre pourquoi comme dans
celle-là où le robot arrive sans ses
phar en pleine ville de nuit à 160 km/h
d'après le bruit de sa
viture pour leur dire je pouvais pas te
voir tuavais pas de gilet vous savez
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on va se mettre à
faire des morales aussi à la fin des
épisodes vu comme ça pe l' trop
dur fais attention avec ce couteau quand
tu veux ouvrir ta bière demande plutôt à
tes parents ou utilise un décapsuleur
tiens merci JDG mais qu'est-ce que vous
faites chez moi ça Billy c'est une autre
histoire d'ailleurs pas mal d'autres
messages d'intérêt général de
Transformers ont été repris aussi dans
d'autres séries fait par le même studio
dont celui dont on va parler on pourrait
penser que des animés adapté de jouer ça
veut surtout dire truc pour garçon mais
non il y avait aussi la même chose pour
fille c'est parti pour j'aimer les
hologrammes la
vous wouh ce générique est trop bien
animé j'ai hâte de voir la suite non
mais comme si on avait le temps
évidemment donc nous retrouvons jerica
qui vient de perdre son père et qui
cherche à récupérer sa société de
production mais le nouveau dirigeant à
vide d'argent veut nommer les missfit
comme nouveau groupe Vette de son label
Roxy et
St ce qu'elle était en train d'attendre
derrière la porte là depuis tout ce
temps e c'est à nous là non il n'a pas
dit notre nom encore je sais pas
j'entends rien Mo finalement Jam
tellement furieuse qu'elle en déplace le
plafond rentre chez elle et par un soir
de tempête reçoit de la
visite jerica Benton je suis venue te
chercher
dépêche-toiard je
t'attends bon en
route tu es sûr que tu as aucune
question là
je suis venu te
chercher mais qu'est-ce qu'on attend
mais non dans les années 80 la vie
n'avait aucune valeur alors allons-y
suivons le fantôme dans son repère
qu'est-ce qu'on risque après tout donc
sans plus se poser de question les
filles suivent l'hologramme qui
s'appelle synergie [ __ ] cette
animation hologramme qui a été réalisé
par le père d'Ica qui a mis des années à
le programmer j'ai des années à me
mettre au ah je veux bien croire qu'il a
mis des années à la programmer synergie
parce que ça doit être chiant de
programmer avec ça quand même ah mais
c'est pas possible comment on ouvre
l'Explorateur
Windows
merde et puis même au-delà du clavier
les lumières ça doit pas aider bref j
récupère tout la tiraille de son père
qui visiblement a aimé collectionner les
robes et les objets Ros fluo mais ça
personne n'a l'air de le relever et s'en
sert pour monter un groupe appelé g et
les hologrammes bref évidemment après
c'est une série tous les épisodes se
passe un peu de la même façon duel de
chanson entre le groupe de G et le
groupe de missfit qui au passage on un
peu carrément une voix de mouru notre
faute si ne sait pas tenir un volant
ouais fa plaisir ensuite les missfit pte
un câble essayent de tuer J et son
groupe là je veux dire sur trois
épisodes elles ont détruit le matériel
du groupe de GEM qui ont failli tomber
de la falaise piquer un buzer pour
détruire un bâtiment mis le feu à un
orphelina saccager une fête sur un
bateau poser une [ __ ] de bombe dans un
autre orphelina risquer de faire
s'écraser un Yach contre un pétrolier et
mis feu à un plateau de tournage
attention et puis d'une manière générale
sortez d'ici d'accord d'accord de toute
façon votre émission n'a pas assez de
classe pour nous ok alors déjà c'est pas
l'miss fit qu'il fallait les appeler
c'est les pétasses et ensuite on va
arrêter de secondes c'est à quel moment
qu'on appelle la police là quand
commence à enfermer les gens dans une
église et qu' foutent le feu non parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'un des gentils
pourrait appeler la police il se
retiennent genre là viennent de
détourner un bateau pour le faire
s'écraser sur un pétrolier oh je devrais
appeler les gardescôte et leur demander
d'arrêter ses Miss fits elle le
mériteraiit et tu ne le fais pas parce
que ah ben oui évidemment mer fait des
intrigues pour bon alors j'allais pas me
taper les 60 épisodes donc on va
directement passer au dernier épisode et
c'est toujours intéressant pour voir
comment une série a évolué donc dans cet
épisode on retrouve Banny une petite
asiatique orpheline dans l'orphelina de
J qui ve retrouver ses parents bref
Banny est déprimé mais j l'aide a
retrouvé le moral grâce à une chanson à
propos de la famille on voit donc
Sherlock Holmes c'est le premier
ministre Chamberlin puis Banny devient
une fermière poursuivie par des pirates
et se fait sauvé par Robin Desbois et le
RO arur qui tire des lasers oh elle lui
chante une chanson ou elle lui fait
fumer des pétards
là mais malgré ce tripos acide qu'elle
vient de faire ban reste triste et veut
vraiment retrouver son père ce qui est
dur puisque tout ce qu'on sait de lui
c'est qu'il est rou et qui s'appelle
Marty bref quasiment impossible à
retrouver et mais non 20 minutes plus
tard ils l'ont trouvé donc bah
finalement ça vaait peut-être le coup de
demander avant vous pouvez retrouver ma
maman non je t'ai dit qu'elle est
impossible à retrouver mais elle est
derrière la
fenêtre tu es orpheline donc finalement
il réussisse à trouver un mec un peu nul
qui serait peut-être le père de manie et
le ramène à l'orphelina puis mais oui ma
belle maintenant ton papa va s'occuper
de toi maintenant tu
verras est-ce que c'est pas l'orphelina
le plus dangereux du mond chose à dire
bibile moi elle s'appelle ban il arrive
même pas à prononcer son nom [ __ ] tu
es sûr que tu veux pas vérifier quand
même avant de lui donner un enfant é ah
ben c'est bon étaent simples les
procédures d'adoption dans les années 80
je suis sûr qu'on pourrait faire un
McDrive ça irait plus vite encore
bonjour je voudrai un enfant s'il vous
plaît c'est pour emporter ou consommer
sur place donc bref pendant ce tempsl
heureusement le vrai père de Ban bien la
sauveré et la fille lui saute dans les
bras ça va aller ça va
aller arrête ça tuen sais rien si c'est
ton père c'est dangereux à force et les
miss F me direz-vous vous savez celles
qui ont essayé de tuer j pendant 60
épisodes qui ont foutu une bombe dans un
orphelina qui ont fait jeter la sœur de
J dans un volcan en éruption et ben ça
se règle comme
ça on peut commencer la fête maintenant
les miss fits sont arrivés si vous êtes
venu pour nous créer des problèmes je
vous mais non on na pas toujours cette
idée en tête on veut simplement donner
un cadeau d'adieu à la petite alors dans
ce
cas er ta sœur dans un volcan qu'est-ce
qui va pas dans vos têtes enfin voilà
c'était j'aimis les hologrammes c'était
effectivement mieux dans mes souvenirs
comm beaucoup de séries d'ailleurs après
je vais pas cracher sur cette série
parce que c'est loin d'être la pire
forcément je suis pas dedans vu que
c'est clairement une série pour jeune
fille mais au moins les héroïnes sont
responsables gè un orphelina et essayent
d'apprendre aux jeunes filles à être
forte c'est pas juste un groupe de
Barbie débiles qui s'habill en rose
comme on pourrait le croire au début en
voyant les jouets les des animés basés
sur des jouets qui soient pour fille ou
pour garçon il y en a des bons des des
moins bons et des très mauvais sur le
principe après c'est pas parce que c'est
un truc commercial fait pour vendre des
jouets que ça sera forcément mauvais
tenez il y a des trucs commerciaux qui
sont bien
j'ai pas d'exemple mais je suis sûr
qu'il y en a donc ben je suis partagé il
y a une partie de moi-même qui me dit
que c'est honteux de taxer l'argent des
gamins mais l'autre qui me dit que j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] que je me suis bien
abusé avec mon shreader et mes tortues
ninja dans la cour de récré donc bah
finalement je regrette pas qu'on ai
sorti une série à partir de la poupée
JDG alors c'est un noir un arabe et un
communiste achète ma toupie prends la
tune de tes vieux tabasse tes abrutes
avec tes doigs grissux dép ta Tune et
constate la tristesse de ta jeunesse
achète ma
m ma
mer achète ma mère achète ma mère ma
merde c'est la bonne merde